go if I was coach I would agree I would
say be a bit more direct but it's not
necessarily Vincent's style he's a very
positional player he likes kind of these
strategic battles as Magnus does it's
going to be a different type of game
today I don't expect Vincent to go
attacking from the off but maybe later
if he gets a chance to mix things up
that's how we beat Prague in the final
game yesterday he randomized it at the
right moment and meanwhile a queen's
Pawn opening and this little Pawn push
this third move
Magnus for the first time in his career
played it in game six of the world
championship last year and a very famous
game
Magnus beats napoleonishi in that one in
seven hours 45 minutes
and that's so yeah so he never really
it's aimed towards getting into a
Catalan opening uh this move order but
he never really played this specific
order until last year Magnus but Vincent
expects it and brings his Bishop out
yeah because that game has been studied
a lot I bet since the world championship
match one of the most historic games
ever yeah a lot a lot like him and we
were sitting here enjoying it well
that's amazing one of my first
experiences and uh it was yeah I mean
that was brilliant for me to come in
with you know you guys and you know
commentate on that historic game and I
think we had a lot of fun uh going over
that game with all its up and down so
yeah it was really really special moment
yeah longest game in world championship
history and it was also magnus's first
win in the match nepo basically tilted
after that
over seven hours incredible game yeah
and Vincent has done his homework I
looked at this myself just very recently
I I tried to play something very similar
uh in the chess Olympiad from the white
side but my opponent chose a different
move order and actually I was more
scared of this move order uh because
black now he will save his lights go
ahead Bishop this last Pawn Push by
black it looks a bit innocent it looks a
bit naive just taking a time out pushing
a pawn but black slight Square Bishop
has a nice Square to retreat to later
and it's actually very difficult for
white to play in the center the critical
ideas for white to bring his Queen out
attack some weak pawns on Black's left
side of the board but
um yeah Magnus seems slightly surprised
I said leeco move if I ever seen one I
reckon but no I mean it's a very logical
move isn't it because the light Square
Bishop I mean what I like about what
Vince has done here he's gone for the
maximum from the opening so if you look
at his light Square Bishop it's uh poked
out on the other side of his pawns and a
lot of times black doesn't bother doing
this but the bishop is so much more
actively in better place there and this
is what we say about you know trying to
get the maximum from from the position
so
um it does come with some risks but he's
saving that Bishop with a little poor
move and I like that just just going for
you know what could well be
strategically the best line and we now
see some quite logical moves and
um here this is again very normal for
London systems but some of the more
shall I say positional London systems
and we have the exchange of Queens David
getting a pretty normalish position yeah
normal-ish but I'm not a huge fan of
White's Bishop on this uh this exact
Square this kind of
wall of Pawns is going to block it out
for a long time in the game Vincent just
moves his Bishop out this is clearly
still preparation I looked at this
position as well myself White's plan
might be to push this Pawn forward
white has double pawns after all but
still Black's position is Rock Solid
and the coins are off white doesn't have
too many Pawn breaks White's only plan
pretty much is to push this Pawn forward
and meanwhile black can just keep the
structure black can actually stop these
pawns advancing at some point
there is one other plan right in the
position for white and that is to put
the as well as pushing those pawns
forward is to develop the light squirt
the dark Square Bishop sorry and uh F4
and then afterwards you expand on the
king side and then just one final plan
this is why I wanted to mention it is
that the Knight can actually re-route
itself the Knight on F3 this is quite
complicated so you'll have to forgive me
it will re-route itself all the way yeah
David's David's got it this this one is
a just a very common plan
very typical plan this is a bit of a
weakness
so long term I would agree but I
remember looking at this a bit and
computers were not impressed at all
and black has resources uh in the
position so let's see what Magnus does
I'm assuming either your Marcus move
here bringing the bishop out or pushing
the pawn and uh you're gonna say Simon
about this Pawn push I was gonna say
yeah I mean when I've played these
positions which is quite rare I
sometimes get tricked into Blitz game
I'd never want to play them I'm always
scared as black of beef this Bertie
coming up the ball Barry the B Pawn
because uh that that you know gets rid
of the pawn but it causes a bit of
pressure against Black's Queen side but
David you notice much better me it's not
something to what you can't stop that
pawn getting there that's probably worth
pointing out you black would love to
stop that idea but he can't and uh I
mean that that would scare me if I was
black here it would I mean I'd be I'd
certainly be worried about this uh this
push
um but it's not a major problem David
you think I mean I guess Vincent studied
this position before or at least is
familiar with the ins and outs so I
think he'll find ways to deal with this
but as you mentioned it's quite nice for
white to have this kind of semi-open a
file with his Rook it means you can get
away with some stuff Meanwhile your
Bankers move on the board bring the
bishop out very logical and I'm
expecting Vincent to maybe move this
night there is a threat to win a pawn
for example Bishop takes Knight now is a
threat just kicking the black Rook away
and a pawn will drop to White Rook so
that Knight really needs to move or you
castle and defend it but in the current
position if I remember correctly black
has two moves so you can bring the
Knight this way or you can bring the
Knight this way it looks a bit odd to
put the Knight on this edge of the board
but then it does stop for white
advancing
and uh yeah it's it's definitely a
technical position and who's that gonna
favor usually I would say Magnus but
Vincent
he knows he knows these types of
positions quite well yeah he's a very
patient player he's what I noticed uh
when I looked at the game that he played
against you is that uh he's got his
opening all worked out
and uh it doesn't didn't seem like you
were playing a teenager at all it just
seemed like you were playing a very very
experienced Grand Master yeah so I
played Vincent last year in the final
round of the grand Swiss and uh I was so
close to winning but uh if I had won I
would have come joined second in the
tournament it would have been playing in
the Grand Prix uh if you did Grand Prix
oh sorry David a lot of uh a lot of
kaching who was involved but uh yeah it
was a draw in the end and like you said
Ivanka very I mean his opening
preparation caught me off guard he was
Rock Solid actually I was a bit worried
I would be worse with whites in that
opening but his play in general which is
very very mature yeah
and talking about teenagers it's great
that we have two teenagers in the
competition maybe we might even see a
teenager in the final and the reason why
I'm mentioning teenager a lot is because
it is competition time we are asking
today what is your funniest teenage
moment and you can send us your answers
using the hashtag chess Champs and one
lucky winner will win a signed This Time
air things view plus such a cool prize
as it is made extra special by our four
signatures hopefully hopefully we
haven't decreased the value
and looking forward to sharing and
reading your tweets and I think this is
one that I might actually try and enter
yeah all right I like it yeah we were
thinking about doing a most embarrassing
teenage moment but um well we went with
funniest yeah everybody can be
embarrassing but uh if you've seen my my
pictures as a teenager you realize that
I I fall in the embarrassing
I don't have any teenage pictures of me
but I would also fall in the category of
embarrassing no doubt No Doubt
all right you guys started thinking we
will obviously ask you guys about
funniest slash the most embarrassing
moment but first do we have some more
interesting moves in the game yeah it's
the most we expected pretty much uh
black just developing his Knights very
solid square and white pushing his Pawn
forward
and this can be prevented
well actually we can't yet but uh White
wants to push his beat his front be Pawn
forward in front of those doubled pawns
and uh Vincent gains a bit of time by
kicking back a white bishop and white
Bishop pucks itself on a bit of a weird
Square this bishop is kind of in limbo
right now it's just staring at its own
pawns but Magnus I guess will be arguing
that he's provoked a slight weakening of
black spawn structure on that right side
what do you think of this uh this last
couple of moves uh all pretty normal I'm
I'm still wondering uh I I'm just
interested more than anything how how
Black's gonna deal with the pawn push
that Magnus is is gonna very shortly
play and I expect Magnus will now uh
play this Pawn push
um I mean I have to say though this this
lunge of the Gary Pawn pushing white
start Square Bishop away is very very
useful for black because uh
um okay Magnus playing on both sides of
the board but I was going to mention his
Bishop the dark Square Bishop was on a
great diagonal magnus's dark squid
Bishop now it's in a really bad square
and I think probably with this movie
he's trying to get that Bishop back to
that diagonal it's more to stop a black
Rook coming over uh which we we might
see obviously a little bit later on
um but I like this move from Magnus he
he's expanding on both sides um with
that one and
um we can see that Vincent just uh
pushes forwards gaining space as well
yeah but uh like you said Simon once the
bishop comes back here uh later blacks
Rook will be able to use the square the
B8 Square will be deprived of that that
post and ivanka's plan the one mentioned
a bit earlier is also in play for
example if black just plays a very
natural move pushes upon the White
Knight is coming and actually
it's very hard for black now to defend
this point uh at this point point Pawn
because right now the White Knight
attacking it as mentioned as well the
black Rook if it ever tries to defend
we'll simply get kicked away White's
pieces all have the perfect squares
Black's Pawn chain will start to crumble
these pawns will just start dropping one
by one so this is where magnus's Knight
is heading the A5 square and Vincent
needs to find an antidote I should also
mention I have bad experiences on the
black side of this Pawn structure bad
recent experiences I lost a game to
Arjun eragisi another semi-finalist in
this Pawn structure when I had black I
defended everything was fine but I just
got really really passive defending
especially this pawn and I think after
50 60 moves my position just cracked uh
it was unable to hold on to all of these
pawns later in the game just like Magnus
is doing he played on both sides of the
board with white so Magnus has a space
Advantage here with some pawns also with
his last Pawn push trying to gain some
space as well
interesting tensing game but uh top
players they they need to master these
Pawn structures and are we already in
the end game only one set of pieces I
have left the board the Queens how often
do we see the that that is the first
piece to be taken off it's true actually
it's the only piece yeah even though the
pawns are still on the board
very rare huh but does that mean we're
in an end game
I'd say middle game yeah
technical term okay
it doesn't look like an end game I will
definitely say that yes I have plenty of
tension here and Vincent increases that
tension by pushing in the center
and I don't think Magnus wants to take
that pawn Black's night will just bring
to life
maybe he just gets on with his plan
yeah I think so yeah I wonder if he'd
push the pawn or move the Knight around
the two plans that you've both mentioned
I mean
um maybe move them night now I guess but
I like this move in the center from
Vincent he's got a he's got to try to
create some counter play uh somewhere
and the center seems like the most
natural place to do that
um I mean I'll be honest this is this is
again this kind of position
is is really a matter of taste isn't it
and my taste would avoid this position
and probably with white I have to say
because
you know it's it's it's refined taste to
play this or you like I see people
especially Club players who go into this
kind of middle game and they've been
doing it for 20 30 years and uh you know
so yeah refined taste I think because a
good thing you know because they don't
I've seen this is one of the problems
with a lot of Club players they stay the
same rating like let's say 1800 all
their life
but they never change their openings or
anything or the way they play they're
like you know they're old you can't
teach an old dog new tricks but you've
got to change it's normal in life to
change yeah I mean just even if it makes
you worse you know just change don't
play the same old stuff all the time you
know you know I changed and I lost like
loads of rating points you're going to
but at least you're learning from losing
right as you said earlier you know
you're learning from the process so it's
uh it's it's all a learning process I
mean I I you know I do say you should
stick with the same openings uh for a
long long time but you should try new
things out surely David yeah what do you
think experimentation is uh normally the
way to find your strengths and
weaknesses and they do say that that's
the definition of Madness right just
doing the same thing time and time again
just expecting different results
it's true so I mean that's where I found
I made my biggest jump as a player was
when I started learning new things
opening my mind
and like Ivanka says I lost plenty of
points in the early days when I was
trying out new openings but eventually
once you master those new structures
those new ideas
it pays off you gain those points back
it's all a journey chess is a journey
and uh meanwhile we did see a Trader
Pawns in the center and Magnus
deciding whether to maybe attack this
black knight in the Middle with his dark
sky Bishop or maybe the White Knight
will move again or push this Pawn it's
like a combination of all the plans
we've discussed
and he's just getting rid of his doubled
pawns first of all but he's also trying
to loosen up Black's Pawn structure and
this pawn it can be traded off but it's
not lost because white has this pin on
the a file White's rook in the corner
does a great job so black can only
capture this Pawn in one way and white
snipe is able to recapture
so just just the softening up of Black's
Pawns
ah still in the balance it's very tense
queenless middle game yeah still a
rarity at least a set of Pawns have
disappeared another set of pawns are
about to disappear it's starting to kind
of clarify the position
but whose favor it's it's still hard to
say I like what Vincent's done just uh
staying very very calm
ing I thought I'd subject the world into
a picture of my teenage self I'm sorry
guys I'm sorry everyone I think I was
around about 16. aha I was 16 I hadn't
yet accepted I had curly hair I didn't
know I had curly hair so I would brush
my hair straight every day and it would
just like grow like this and uh yeah
there I was I was playing I was an E4
player then and I was playing at the
British championships I think that's in
Torquay and I was yeah had big glasses
as well yeah like yeah yeah that was
yeah completely different I have to say
I mean I think you can maybe mention
this time when we went to playing the
under 20 World Championships talking
about
um funny moments
um there was a photo it's a great photo
I've got to find out I won't be able to
find it today but if you follow us on
Twitter with me and Ivanka at the Disco
there but
um that was after the last round I think
you know we're about 18 19 years old and
um I do remember
um one funny moment but yeah do you want
to yeah it was it was okay it was one of
those drunken moments probably my most
embarrassing thing I've ever did
um which is just
got drunk and I poured some beer over a
Grandmaster oh but I was in fairness he
wasn't you know he made a bet and he
didn't stick to his deal so his part oh
so you did it wasn't the no I didn't
deliberately but it was a drunken thing
and I think I asked Simon and Simon goes
yeah go for it
yeah another time I like the way you
think that you asked why you asked me
you know what I'm gonna say you're like
Simon should I throw a point over this
person's face of course you should
Ivanka it's a good idea look at that you
know that he should he he's made a deal
he's broken it of course and so oh it's
brilliant I remember it this this point
going flying uh all over this um
everyone has that dream at some point to
just go up to an edit and just throw a
point over them yep I like it you might
go yeah I've never done it since can we
name this Grandmaster no no no no no no
but in 80 years I actually I I met him
again and I was actually playing
adjacent to him you know he before that
he'd had kind of had a firm he would not
making any eye contact with me
whatsoever but because I changed so much
you know I'd lost quite a lot of weight
I didn't have any glasses my hair was
Curly you know reckon he was like
looking at me again and then he saw my
name and he goes
yeah
sorry I like it so we have a fun story
from teenage years in the studio bring
us yours as well using hashtag chess
Champs One winner will get an air things
device sign bye everyone in the studio
even the bear is where we're here
[Laughter]
on your nickname
for a while
I have to say don't mess with your
Banker if you see Ivanka out and about
make sure you polite otherwise you might
be getting a beer over your face no your
Anka's too lovely for that I'm only I'm
only joking that it was a long time ago
yeah have you ever all sports seem to
have English Hooligans
I mean I mean Ivanka have been the
English who look at it just doesn't no
no it just doesn't work does it not at
all so it was well deserved I think at
the time well I don't know I was drunk
[Laughter]
all right well going back to the board
two uh Knights on
um
supporting each other I don't know maybe
not that but they're all next to each
other yeah supporting their pawns and
yeah these nights on the queen side for
white look pretty good they're ready to
jump in if necessary right now though
it's still about this tension with the
white B Pawn now I'm just to clarify
just to reiterate it cannot be captured
this way because the black Rook would
fall Rook takes Rook is not protected
this would be a deadly check white would
win a piece and likewise black doesn't
really want to capture the other way
right now firstly white could safely
take this Pawn due to the pin again but
the Central Pawn might look even more
juicy
take this Pawn off you're attacking this
bishop you're threatening to jump in
with a nasty check a nasty fork and
White's night would just be too powerful
to deal with so it's a bit awkward for
events and he doesn't really want to
touch this Pawn Magnus has just kind of
jumped to the square with his Knight
defending the other pawn and
okay what ideas could Black come up with
if he doesn't really want to change the
pawn structure
any uh any suggestions here
I just don't really like Black's
position I mean I know that it's
probably totally playable maybe I'm a
bit biased but it just seems like white
has all the ideas all the ideas that
both of you have mentioned have been
white ideas I mean where a black side is
in this position what what should black
be doing here to to uh get some counter
play I mean I I don't know it's a good
question I mean the first move that came
to my mind was planting the Knight on
this Square you're attacking White's
Bishop you're attacking this Pawn but
White's Bishop could move from any
potential exchange gain at move gain
temper as well hitting this Rook I guess
black could castle for example I mean
you can move this Rook it's still not
late too late to Castle the king not
necessarily to safety this time but just
uh at least now you're connecting your
Rooks and you're asking a question
finally of this Pawn
okay to me this looks very natural maybe
there were some tactics for example in
this position of a trade of Pawns and
White's night jumping forward something
like this where suddenly this dormant
Bishop comes to life and uh some tricks
like this I think this is what perhaps
scared Vincent into playing the move
we'd see on the board uh Vincent was
maybe scared of a sacrifice on this
Square blowing the position open has
retreated his peace
suddenly yeah suddenly after this move I
agree with you Simon suddenly this is a
passive piece I don't really like the
momentum for black where did Black go
wrong yeah I mean maybe he's still fine
but yeah maybe I mean maybe it's just
that type of position which looks nice
for white but still hard to crack for
black yeah okay we have a draw in game
one between Liam Lee and Arjun Erika
silian with the white pieces only 20
minutes that first game lasted it is a
draw they will now have 15 minutes to
rest and prepare for game two where
Arjun aragus you will have the white
pieces tied after one out of four rapid
games in their semi-final match
this one seems like a lot of play left
in this game a lot of play left in uh
the other game they played doubly as
fast they played 35 moves and we're
still only 18 here so uh yeah Speedy
stuff from the Vietnamese player and the
Indian player does that mean we are
bound to see some time trouble in this
game do you think it's possible
um depends how much more the position
simplifies over the next few turns
yeah I mean there's still enough tension
uh it feels like Magnus wants to obtain
a Time Advantage he's playing slightly
quicker casting his King now again not
about King safety more just to get his
Rooks connected but uh
yeah it's hard to say I have a feeling
that Vincent in a few of the games today
will be under some time pressure uh when
I've played him both online in lots of
speeches but also over the board in that
game a big Grand Swiss time pressure it
did occasionally
uh play a part so black does the same
black copies castles
still very tense I think I remember from
his quarter final yesterday against
Prague that he handled time trouble very
well Vincent yeah he gets low on the
clock as far as I remember but he
handles it well when you're young he
calculates so quickly like Winston does
it's easier to
navigate when you're down on the clock I
guess I mean there is a pawn in Pre now
I mean sorry just looking at the
tradition yeah I mean Black's castled
and he's left his uh Harry porn on pre
and I'm just thinking well you know I
see a pawn I grab a pawn um you know and
obviously you should look at the most
critical moves first uh you shouldn't
you shouldn't believe your opponent
um you should work out what happens if
you take this Pawn I mean I don't know
if you take it first of all or grab a
pawn first but what what is going on if
we just grab that pawn and attack The
Rook
feels like I mean I that was completely
off my radar for a second I just
completely forgot as Vincent forgotten
surely not but where does he move his
Rook
I mean I guess he's going to get enough
counter play on The Queen side somehow
um something like this but maybe even
this Square would be clever just uh
because the position's about to open
this Pawn is attacked yeah if I can see
a Trader Pawns
The Rook comes to life yeah and this is
probably
um Vincent's idea to get enough counter
playing okay Magnus going for something
else instead yeah yeah take this Pawn
but it's still there it's up for grabs
yeah I was going to say I think he's oh
he takes it and uh I think we'll see The
Rook go to the open Line attacking in
the night and uh now the Knight
centralizes itself
that's pretty I mean it's hard to
evaluate this position this Pawn is up
for grabs uh Black's Rook can get active
but again the White Knight looks really
well placed uh this Pawn is defended
right now but it's an eternal weakness
so hard to call maybe the simplest move
would be to take this Pawn with the
bishop just to kick away this really
strong Knight ask it to make a decision
at least
if we see a knight takes Bishop trade at
least Black's got rid of his bad Bishop
and who knows I mean evaluation bar
thinks blacks may be even slightly
better but
I'm biased I would take the Bishops I'll
take white perhaps
how about you guys how would you
evaluate this position
Black's got lovely lovely Pawns in the
center there it seems to me uh and you
know nice open file for The Rook uh it's
but as you say it's really hard to
evaluate
um
I don't know I mean I I guess roughly
even it is kind of fair with chances
both sides is just a fair assessment of
this kind of position really yeah yeah I
feel the same you know it's so
dynamically balanced and you know yeah
black has got a nice horns but you know
white has got a protected outside Pawn
over there Harry
oh and that could be something that does
a lot of damage when the pieces get
traded off and of course and of course
what has the bishop power as well so
both sides have got the their advantages
I don't know
it's gonna get messy this is the thing
with this kind of position you know it
did look like white was controlling the
pace of the game but now it looks like
it's completely wild anything can happen
and I feel that the position is so
critical that we're going to see who is
going to get the advantage in the next
space or the moves yeah the next few
moves are essential and I was about to
say maybe it's time for Magnus to just
blow open the position and he does that
if the these pawns get exchanged
suddenly this white Bishop the fiend
Bishop will come to life on this
diagonal got some targets there suddenly
the White Knight if these pawns
disappear the White Knight might get
into the game centralize
I love this last move by white but
clearly black is solid enough it's
getting really complicated gotta
calculate I'm surprised Vincent didn't
take this Pawn on the last move because
uh now suddenly he has to start counting
for example if Bishop takes porn what
happens if Pawn takes Pawn this is
another capture and another capture and
another capture and another capture and
it's like oh that's the brain so I think
in Practical terms it was maybe wise not
to not to allow all this chaos
but Magnus he's jumped on the
opportunity and we might well see that
variation after the pawn has stepped
forward because black does indeed
capture and suddenly this Knight is on
priests oh there's tactics here I mean
this is an idea Knight takes porn with a
double attack here he got the other way
haven't you can you not take the bishop
and take twice on D5 as well I mean that
that looks uh I guess black is getting
off counter play but this is so much to
calculate here and I want to open up the
light Square Bishop yeah with this move
peace
um I mean
I I you know I I look at this and I I
look at unfortunately evaluation bar is
like feisty my my view as is just 0.0
and I'm like come on evaluation bar get
your act together are you still waking
up what's going on with you today it's
not nice when you're being flatlined by
the evaluation you know you're getting
really excited about the positions
nothing going on yeah the computer says
nice
look at from my point of view I look at
the position I'm like Yay in the Park
yeah that was that's uh waking me up but
it's certainly not boring is it David
yeah I mean this this is certainly not
just 0.0 nothing going on exactly yeah I
mean Magnus right now here he's burnt
one minute but he has to burn even more
time he's got this capture to calculate
as we showed this one as we showed and
also politics porn on the radar
um so three viable captures which all
lead to five six move variations
oh I don't envy the norwegian's task
right now to calculate all of this
is going to have to spend a lot of time
critical moment as we said and the bar
it's I think it's ready to shoot in
either direction it might go very far to
White's favor also could go the other
way and he's taken the pawn and uh yeah
still loads of things to calculate as
you highlighted
oh God too much because it's like every
single move you know there's like the
three the the captures the checks the
threats look at that I mean just look at
the minor pieces look at the knights and
Bishops they they give me a headache I
mean they're all over the place in the
middle once like someone randomly threw
them onto the board exactly yeah just
get the pieces and whack them on and
they have no real like normal Harmony
you know they're just very very random
but spread out it's a good offended yeah
and it's clearly a critical moment isn't
it now this is where at this moment the
game could easily turn to one size favor
slight in accuracy and you're going to
lose this now okay
yeah exactly
I mean the way I would approach this is
if I was Vincent if I were taking down
on the clock I would think okay how can
I just control things first I would do
the calculation if it was still a blur
in my mind which it is right now
um then I would just try and control
things okay it's level pawns right now
if you could maybe just
for the craziness stop all the fun trade
off some pieces maybe that would be one
solution black Central Pawn could just
push forward try and block it up
keep things closed but yeah in the end
it's it's so hard if you get caught up
in the moment with there he goes I think
maybe the most human move
does allow this one wow Magnus leaving
his Knight at the top of the board to
get captured but he's attacking Black's
Rook that White Knight on the edge of
the board attacking Black's rook and
attacking Black's dark squared Bishop
everything's hanging his really yeah a
really hard should Vincent now take the
White Knight
I think he needs to save his Rook okay
that black Rook on the second rank
it's attacked right now by the night on
the edge of the board you can't get rid
of that Knight at least obviously you
want to capture white pieces but the
Rook is the most important right now and
okay he does Shuffle it one square to
the side
we see Black's Dark Side Bishop fall
which Knight do you take even right now
um you can take both of those two white
Knights you can choose you take this one
I am surprised at that one actually I
thought that he would preserve his
Bishop I think you have to be careful of
the Pawn in the center didn't mean that
that was the problem and uh but now
Magnus as you said you've anchor you can
get the two they can get the bishop pair
if he wants he can grab that that bishop
and it'll be two Bishops versus zero and
and Magnus loves those positions and it
does seem quite open maybe he can sack a
pawn in the middle to open them up more
but visually again uh this shows how
little I'm understanding of this game I
really like White's position because I'm
sort of just uh I'm just counting up the
pawns as well okay I'm doing a bit slow
today and it is four pawns each but the
two Bishops look lovely okay and he
hasn't done that why did he take the
Knight and not the bishop that's not a
question for me because I don't know
good question I think it's so that he
could play this move um if you'd taken
the bishop instead then Black's Knight
which would have then been on the board
could have captured this point one now
the remaining Black Knight cannot
capture this Pawn because look at
White's light squared bishop and look at
the black rook in the corner they're on
the same diagonal Black's Knight is
actually pinned on that diagonal right
now so I think he just wanted to open up
his Bishop that was uh the priority and
he's focusing on his own pieces would
Alpha zero take
um
the other one because it loves the
bishop here quite possibly
um I think it's a matter of taste from a
human point of view but uh it's still
unclear we'd probably have to analyze
that position for quite a while to
decide uh which capture was best in the
end Vincent he's just trying to
eliminate white Central Pawn I think
this is a good decision that he's made
moving his Rook to the e-line you know
he's just simply saying let's change the
nature of the position so that all the
pawns remain on one side of the board
and that that way the bishop pairs just
slightly less effective
and uh well decision time from Magnus is
he gonna try to hold on to the pawn or
is he perhaps forced to play Rook takes
pawn and uh try to work the position
from all angles
and whilst Magnus is thinking I know
this is a super tense position but I
have a few more stories to share with
you do I have time yes the first one
teenage Blues I bet you I bet you'll
recognize this young fella
is it David
I actually did that David yeah nice and
uh and uh very nice and Robbie tells us
a story that says talking of drunken
stories I have a few a happy one is this
Smith and Williamson young masters in
Guildford drunkenly remember being in
the pub and had an arm wrestle does it
does this ring any bells by the way I
don't know who Robbie is but I do I do
remember the Smith Williamson young
masters and I I do remember various
stories going on there
um and I am but I can't remember arm
wrestling Robbie in the pub
but it probably happens I remember there
was a lot of car surfing going on and
I'll just I'll just leave it at that
okay
interesting
arm wrestling I bet you'll give it that
Simon we did uh see uh both the players
now make moves yeah both players
capturing pawns so both the central
pawns have disappeared and this is a key
move from Vincent white remember had the
two Bishops we normally Rave about the
two Bishops we love them especially on
an open board as this one is right now
but if the light squared bishops get
traded off
it's less clear all of White's pawns are
on one side of the board and knights
tend to be good when it's just pawns on
one side of the board so a good exchange
I think a necessary exchange by Vincent
the Black Knight as well is ready to
jump in
um if these Bishops disappear to a
really juicy Square the F3 Square watch
out for some Black Knight jumps some
checks Forks
oh it's only I don't know maybe I'd
prefer taking black
it's it's just one of those games it's
like we're changing our opinion on every
move but in terms of ease of play
Vincent's found a clear plan the Black
Knight in the center of the board is
just fantastic
and uh it's up to Magnus now how does he
try to keep pieces on the board how does
he try to keep tension and winning
chances not easy
enough as well ticking under three
minutes on the clock and I need to know
who Robbie is as well so Robbie please
let me know your real name
but um I agree with you David I mean
this this position doesn't seems like
you know Black's pieces are harm nosing
a bit better here uh um you know in the
center of the board at the moment so
yeah and you know you can even see some
and I know I'm getting a bit ahead of
myself but you can even see some danger
for the white king you know I'm looking
at those check mating possibilities and
I'm thinking well you know if a knight
launches itself on the F3 Square the
white king doesn't have too many squares
to go to it's in a cage so this is
something that white will have to bear
in mind yeah maybe we have to show this
because it's going to be really relevant
uh in a second
um let's say I don't know which move
okay white moves this rock up and this
idea might be on the board if Ivanka
black could give a check uh this king is
really stuck he doesn't really want to
go into the corner probably not so
capture here and as you mentioned this
is a mating net it's a box
and uh you can never get out of the box
because the bishop controls all of your
Escape squares and
all black needs to do is conquer the
first rank for example a big mistake
here would be to bring this Rook up and
this would be Checkmate this is a very
typical amazing pattern called the
don't know what type of chat mate it is
your anchor
um
my favorite one you can call it the
David Checkmate
but there's already a David checked me
howl Checkmate and is it yeah that's
David and Goliath
[Music]
like a howl do you even got an opening
as well ah the whole attack it's not
named after me alas
well so this this night check is
possible you could also make an argument
for trading off the Bishops and then
planting your knight in here and again
there are all sorts of checkmates for
example the black Rook coming in and
behind and Checkmate next move this is
called the heck mate hook Checkmate yeah
no idea why but let's go check mate
isn't a hook it's hook hook line and
sink I know I don't know chess unboxing
it's a thing and we actually have a
video of Chess boxing Simon commentating
on that strange but very cool sport we
will show it to you either today or
during the big final
yeah so right now Vincent critical
moment he needs to I think choose one of
these two moves either throw his Knight
in with a check he'll end up with a
bishop on the Square or if he wants to
trade off the Bishops he can also end up
with a knight on the Square I'm not sure
which one I would want to be honest
it's uh it's a hard call but either way
magnus's King is going to be in a bit of
trouble perhaps he's got to be really
careful walk a tightrope there
so let's
see what Vincent chooses under one
minute now needs to speed up he's played
I mean superbly so well uh so far
yeah you just got to be careful at the
time at the moment I mean his position
as you mentioned is it looks great I
would say because okay the evaluation
bar might say even but generally it's
who has the initiative uh has the better
chances because you put pressure on your
opponent and we know Magnus maybe
doesn't like defending
um if he can help it so
um Vincent's just got to move and uh you
know he's spending too long on this move
though far too much five seconds
I think he's being a bit of a
perfectionist this is the one thing I've
noticed with both Vincent and his coach
peterleko the perfectionists which is
great but
sometimes in speeches Gotta Move gotta
just choose one across those instincts
three minutes almost okay here he comes
yep he trades off the Bishops we said
this was fine another Black Knight I'm
assuming we'll jump in Black's Pawn on
the other side of the board the a pawn
is just gonna drop off eventually both
of the white Rooks are looking at it uh
then white will have a three versus two
Pawn advantage on the right half of the
board but it's more about the placement
of pieces and the Black Knight is going
to be super strong four seconds with
that move wow he spent too much time I
think I mean like this position is quite
easy to play uh thankfully if you can
just throw the Rook down and go for that
hook check mate great and you've got to
just try to activate your Rooks really
this is the the key thing and play your
pieces and but I suspect Magnus might
take the liberty and actually get greedy
[Music]
I don't want to bring in your Rook on
the first rank off the first rank you
want to take the pawn maybe with your
Rook on the sixth round yeah
I was also wondering if you could go
after so the reason Black Knight is so
strong is because there's a pawn
protecting it maybe you could go after
that pawn as well but I think if you
take the point if you take the pawn
black probably has a force draw order
um by by just attacking on sent Frank
some but I think Magnus will be happy
now to get a draw in this position
because it is dangerous for him so uh
um an ambitious guy though maybe he'll
be trying to make use of the fact Vince
it's on 14 seconds yeah I mean you can
also try to attack sort of this Pawn
that's holding Black's position together
on the king side and there's a pawn
that's stabilizing the Black Knight and
you've got to look at these key points
in the position if you can remove that
pawn then then Black's position actually
falls apart so that's another thing
where my eyes are drawn to yeah and as
Davis shows there maybe The Rook can
come over and and aim for that one but
this is very risky because black can
support that pawn and uh unless you've
got a follow-up here Black's still got
that hook Checkmate on the horizon
they're coming down and behind and
Checkmate So It's Tricky actually it's
really tricky you know Magnus has to be
careful here very very careful and uh
maybe take the spawn I'll see if I can
imagine and that's why the bar despite
all this excitement just says guys it's
just 0.0 you know what I do here Simon
offer a draw
well Magnus now down to 30 seconds I
think it's a first round nerves today
but also just high quality game by both
sides they both started really fast
Vincent keeping Pace with the world
champion matching him move for move look
at his eyes Vincent they just it seems
like they're looking all over the board
constantly yeah do you think he's he
keeping an eye on the clock uh is he
looking at magnus's camera perhaps as
well uh he must have been surprised the
world champion went down so low and now
Vincent under 10 seconds white did take
that pawn
so I think he can get that draw now
David if he wants to there is a way you
can force the draw and that's by just
checking the king I was going to bring
by moving
oh moving the Black Knight to attack the
King this is the check the Black Knight
can go back where it came from second
time we've seen this position maybe
we're gonna see the game fizzle out to a
draw because black is a pawn down black
needs to do something but white can't
escape without getting checkmated and
wow a draw in the end what a game
eventually a draw in game one Vincent
the black